Neil degrass Tyson was being a really
good
sport uh and he answered some wackpack
questions and he talked with Bigfoot our
bearded friend from Vermont Bigfoot had
a good question want to know about death
hi this is Bigfoot he Mr scientist man
what happens to after we die Bigfoot
good question so for me I spend my life
dining upon the Flora and Fauna of the
world so when I die I want to be
buried so that my body can be
consumed by flora and fauna just as I
had consumed them thereby returning the
energy content of my body back into the
ecosystem now if you want instead to be
cremated something different happens to
the energy content of your body when you
cremated these large molecules of your
body break apart and release energy he
heating the air in the chimney of the
Smoke Stack of the
crematorium that air gets heated and
radiates infrared light into space
Forever at the speed of light so in that
way all the energy that you once were is
handed out to the greater Universe
rather than kept here on Earth and by
the way knowing I'm going to die is what
gives urgency and meaning
to everything I do great answer he told
you the scientific answer to what
happens to the energy that's contained
in your body now we were curious what
the hell did Bigfoot retain after the
answer was over we asked him here's
here's what Bigfoot said explain to me
what did the scientist say happens when
you die I don't give a [__] what happens
to my body I'm dead I'm dead scientist
can go to hell as far as I care he said
something about space is and stuff like
that yeah and I don't understand what
you're trying to get to your body dies
you explain to when they burn in in a
fire is all the energy goes up into
space and ever and ever and ever yes you
got that part and tan mom asked Neil
degrass Tyson a question I I don't think
I think Neil degrass Tyson left uh left
the country after he got the these
questions but he was very sweet about it
tan mom asked Neil the question as old
as life itself hi Mr scientist this is
can ROM my question for you is what is
the meaning of life tan mom thanks for
asking so often people say I'm looking
for meaning implying that meaning is
something out there waiting to be found
by you is it under a rock behind a tree
in a monastery you go looking for it and
I'm not satisfied with with that as a
solution to the question I think we have
the power to create meaning in our life
meaning for me is I I want to know a
little more tomorrow about the world
than I know today that brings meaning to
my life and I also with whatever even
occasionally trifling investment of my
time and energy and
resources lessen the suffering of others
so that the world is better off for you
having lived in it I beseech you to
treasure up in your hearts these my
parting
words be ashamed to die until you have
won some victory for
Humanity there is the source of meaning
I got to hand it to him that's a good
answer because what again it's based in
fact there is no meaning for Life unless
you give it is there is no meaning
that's right that's it that's what he's
saying so we checked in with tamom see
what she got out of that what he said so
Patricia explain to me what did he just
say he was saying the power of life is
not under a rock or a tree and the power
of life to him to him would be what you
can find in yourself instead of looking
all over the place um for answers it the
power is within you well that's profound
so in your own words what did the
scientists really say is the meaning of
life I'm sorry I'm so distracted with
I'm in a salon right now she can't think
because she's in a
salon hey I get
that